there's no willingness or realistic
expectation that Putin is ready to do
any kind of deal the the process of any
kind of end game is still politically
very far away and there's still an awful
lot of fighting to be done the the
discussions will come and I suspect will
be extremely painful if the Americans
are right I mean we've seen a lot of
material being leaked officially
unofficially through the press and
through internet leaks from the American
defense establishment that are very
pessimistic about the Ukrainian chances
of a breakthrough I'm just quoting what
we understand the American military's
view to be that Ukraine is not going to
achieve militarily the goals that it's
set politically and that's going to be a
really difficult conversation but as an
an extremely painful political process
but as yet Ukraine is very far from
being ready to have that